- [Instructor] In other
videos we have talked about
the various empires of India
as we exit the Vedic period.
We talk about the Maurya Empire
famous for the ruler Ashoka who converts
and then spreads Buddhism.
As we get into the Common Era
we've talked about the Gupta Empire
that once again unifies much of India,
and is considered a golden
age in India's history.
But after the fall of the
Gupta Empire India fragments
and you could roughly consider this
to be the Indian medieval period.
This is what India looks
like in the year 1000
where you have multiple Hindu kingdoms.
Now as we get into the second
millennium of the Common Era,
you start to have
significant Muslim influence.
At first in the northwest
but as we get into the late
12th and early 13th century
you have the establishment
of the Delhi Sultanate
and once again North India is now unified
under Muslim rule which
will continue for some time
under both the Delhi Sultanate
and the Mughal Empire
until the British show up.
And then eventually in 1947,
India becomes an independent country.
But as much transformation as there is
depicted in this map in terms
of various empires and rulers,
you also see a transformation
in the nature of Hinduism.
In other videos we have
talked about the Vedas
composed over 3,000 years ago
in the subset that is
focused on the metaphysical,
on the spiritual known as the Upanishads.
And this is an excerpt
from the Isha Upanishad
which is considered one
of the most important
that emphasizes this
notion of our inner Self,
capitalized with an S, atma or atman
and how it is of the
same substance as this
formless, nameless ultimate reality
sometimes referred to as Brahman.
The Wise man, who realizes all beings
as not distinct from his own Self, atman,
and his own Self as
the Self of all beings,
does not, by virtue of that
perception, hate anyone.
What delusion, what sorrow
can there be for that wise man
who realizes the unity of all existence
by perceiving all beings as his own Self?
And so you have this very abstract idea,
some folks would call it monistic.
All is one.
Your true self is of the same
substance as my true self
which is of the same substance
and is the same thing
as the ultimate reality.
But the Vedas also focus on rituals
and there are also gods in the Vedas.
In particular some of the gods
that are mentioned most frequently.
You have Indra who is the god of lightning
and the god of storms
also referred to in the
Vedas as the king of gods.
You have Agni, the god of fire.
It come from the same root word as ignite.
You have Varuna, the god of water.
But a question, how do we
bridge that to the gods
and the practices of modern Hinduism?
As we've talked about in
other videos on Hindu deities,
most Hindus today view
themselves as devotees of Shiva
or devotees of Vishnu.
And even though Vishnu is
mentioned in the Vedas,
he is by no means the focus.
Modern Hindu practice is
really focused on devotion
to Shiva and/or Vishnu or aspects of them
or incarnations of them.
For example, Rama or Krishna.
How did Hinduism evolve in this way?
And the answer is the Bhakti movement.
And the word Bhakti can be translated as
devotion or devotional love.
And it's believed to have
come out of South India
in the seventh century.
Some people would call
it a reform of Hinduism
that up until that point focused on
the somewhat arcane rituals of the Vedas.
And the Bhakti movement
provided an alternate path,
a path of devotion
Through devotion through a deity
one can achieve that moksha.
Some people would consider
it a reform movement,
some people would say it was always there.
Some historians think that
it might have even been in
reaction to Muslim influence
where there was this devotion
or this surrender to a notion of god.
Some historians think that it co-developed
with Sufi Islam which is all about
devotional love for God.
But needless to say,
as we go through the Indian middle ages,
the Bhakti movement gains
more and more momentum
and it's really the defining
movement for Hinduism today.
And just to get an appreciation
for some Bhakti text
here is an excerpt from the Bhagavad Gita
which is considered by many modern Hindus
to be one of their most
central scriptures.
It was likely written over 2,000 years ago
and really came into its final form
during the Gupta Empire.
But the Gita is considered one
of the central Bhakti text.
And even though the Gita does focus a lot
on notions of realizing the self
and the ultimate reality and
the importance of meditation,
it also makes clear that there's a path
to self-realization through
love, through devotion.
This is Krishna, the eighth
incarnation of Vishnu
talking to the archer Arjun
as he goes into battle.
It's a bit of a repudiation
of what at the time in medieval India
was becoming a more and
more rigid caste structure.
I look upon all creatures equally
none are less dear to
me and none more dear.
And it is also very inclusive.
It is not saying that one
needs to only worship Vishnu
or only worship Shiva.
Those who worship other
gods with faith and devotion
also worship me.
Not a fixation on being absolutely true
to all of the rituals in the Vedas.
Whatever I am offered in
devotion with a pure heart,
even if it's a leaf, a
flower, a fruit or water,
I accept with joy.
With that, I'll leave you with a bhajan,
a big part of the Bhakti movement
of this notion of devotional
love to God is singing.
(singing in foreign language)